an alleged kidnapping ends with a police
officer shooting the kidnapper while two
of the victims were taken to the
hospital thank you for joining us here
at four I'm Kirsten Joyce and I'm Brian
Loftus this marks the third
officer-involved shooting in Metro's
jurisdiction this year eight news now
reporter Ryan Matthey live near lamb and
Charleston with the miles traveled
before the gunshot
yeah Brian Kirsten what police and
security footage shows us is that the
kidnapping car zoomed down Charleston
here just to get stopped a few feet away
this is the area Metro was really
focusing in on you might be able to see
some of the markings on the ground still
according to them it all began with a
text message from one of the people
being kidnapped
right in front of this store here with
about three SWAT trucks the acting
manager of this auto shop who does not
want to be identified was not allowed
inside his store Friday morning he and
others say Metro Police told businesses
to remain closed as they investigated
other than the police presence it was
very desolate there was nobody hardly
around
but it began nearly 25 miles away
Boulder City police saying a woman
texted 9-1-1 stating she had just been
kidnapped before 12 30 Friday morning
once police located them the driver took
off here is where Boulder City PD says
the vehicle Pursuit began near the 95 in
Black Hills before Metro Police took
over near Owens and Hollywood in the
Northeast Valley it ended near lamb and
Charleston security footage from a
nearby business shows six marked police
cars chasing a white vehicle before
stopping just off camera after 2 30.
they were able to forcibly stop that
vehicle Captain Joshua Martinez with
Metro's internal oversight in
constitutional policing Bureau says four
people in total were inside the car
three of them believed to be victims the
suspect allegedly pointing a firearm at
one of the victims before an officer
fired theirs officer discharged his
weapon striking the suspect the suspect
was tended to by Medical on scene and
was transported to Area Hospital and is
in critical condition
now the identity is in the medical
statuses of those three victims have yet
to be released but per Metro policy the
names of those shooting officers
involved would have to be released after
a 48-hour period with all the other
specifics of the investigation at the
72-hour period reporting live near
Charleston and lamb Ryan Matthey 8 News
Now